if your condition if your condition is
prophecies
you definitely accept in islam hands
down if your condition
is that i want to give you this book
here this book is called the forbidden
prophecies
it's wrote by uh this talks about all
the prophecies people made this is a
gift from me to you i'll answer your
question how did the quran know this
but are you going to get i don't know
answer me
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products their products are
fantastic health supplements and also
from the sunnah the website is in the
description link below you can also use
a discount code
salaam 10 for 10 of their
and products this temple will be
destroyed he said you kill me i'm coming
back from the dead
he said i will do this and he did that
multiple times
now if muhammad is a true prophet he
must have prophesied yes
not just about people of the sandals
yeah
can you open that box and there's a book
called profit uh end of the times book
yeah
open it you know the black thing take it
out yeah yeah yeah
there's a book let me tell you something
there is not one prophecies there is
hundreds of prophecies in the quran
in the quran and hadith no no no no
go to go to the go to the book of rome
yeah go to the room yeah so not only do
you have the crew if you want you can
borrow this book for a week's version of
that
you can borrow this book for a week
bring it back next week i'm here yeah
i'm only here once a month
uh it's like okay the end of the world
right okay let me tell you something
when
you ask the idea at the end of the day
no problem no problem no no if that was
the case
about abraham dave dave if that's the
time
let me tell you something how else did
you get it well you asked me a question
let me answer it joseph at the time of
joseph in the bible
what is the rule of code what is the
rule what is the rule of code
called at the time of joseph in the
bible
pharaoh it's called a pharaoh it's
called a pharaoh
right and and and at the time and at the
time of moses
he's called a pharaoh now if the quran
copied from the bible
the quran talks about we have a whole
chapter called yusuf joseph his story
but he doesn't call him the quran
doesn't mention
pharaoh it calls him a king king a malik
now the thing is you have one so you
don't say the discrimination up in india
how about that equality yes so now
yes so now when joseph in the quran
allah talks about moses and he talks
about the time of joseph
but at the time of joseph the rule is
called the king and at the time of moses
moses is called the pharaoh
but in the bible listen carefully in the
bible the bible calls both of them
pharaohs if i'm not mistaken both in
pharaoh and they're nearly illuminated
one second look
no no no no no you're king james king
james king james king james yes
king james james he's the most happy one
but you've got to go back to the hebrew
and greek
that's where you get the most dave let
me make you ask are you
dave you asked you asked you asked for
prophecies yeah
now this is an historical fact because
when they deciphered the hieroglyphics
that was it a stone they deciphered the
hieroglyphics and what they found in the
hieroglyphics is that at the time of
joseph there were no pharaohs
they were kings there was no such title
as pharaohs
now the question that needs to be asked
is the following the quran is copying
from the bible
but the quran corrects the bible and
doesn't call the ruler
a pharaoh but calls them a king it
distinguishes at the time of moses they
were pharaohs
now your bible if it's from god that's a
historical mistake because there was no
pharaohs at the time of joseph
if the translation in the kingdom it is
king james open it open it according to
the
hebrew and the greek yes there are a few
things in the king james you think
so this is according to one you see
history you've got to be careful with
history you say history says this hang
on a minute
history is written by the victim so we
need to look we need to
access different historical
these are not muslims these these
archaeologists doing their job
i'm asking you a question how did the
quran know this
i don't know dave don't brush it aside i
don't need to i haven't looked at it
okay
you need to now you need to look into
that look into that if it if it is true
if it is true i come across most things
no problem and i will look at it no
problem
now the question is if muhammad
david um all these prophets they
prophesied because
you've got now give me genuine
prophecies yes
from muhammad there's many for example
the prophet
no no there's many this book there's
hundreds yeah there's hundreds hundreds
hundreds hundreds
now the first thing the prophet peace be
upon him said for example was
the the battle that happened between ali
and aisha his wife there was a battle
that happened between them yeah and he
specifically says
specifically that i shot rather anger
would be in the wrong
she would should be she would have
oppressed ali yes she would have she
would have made a mistake
and it says specifically that there will
be a time
where there will be dogs kind of not
chasing her
but encircling her yeah and that she
will be in the wrong
and the prophet is telling ali when that
happens
forgive her now this very instance
is uh documented in bukhari and muslim
if i'm not mistaken
and it mentioned this very instance and
the prophet peace be upon him for
example
he prophesies to one of his companions
that he will be wearing the bracelets of
kisrah
the persian empire by name and this is
when
the islamic empire hasn't expanded when
they defeated persia
the very companion wore the bracelets of
persia the ruler
of persia yeah so that's number two i'll
give you many
in the quran the chapter uh wrong yeah
it talks about
and this is historical the persians
defeated the romans and the romans
back then yeah in the sixth century in
the sixth century yeah
the persians and the rome they were
fight rome uh byzantine empire were
having a
war the persians defeated the romans
historians say the way the romans were
defeated so badly
for them to come back was near
impossibility the quran says in the in
the quran in
chapter rome the first chapter gulen
better room the romans have been
defeated
but they will become victorious in a
matter of three to seven years
so he specifically prophesied
specifically in the quran
yes quran quran this is i'm giving quran
hadith it's a little mixture yeah
check them out how do they enough it's
so crucial because
dave davis is a fake i'm not finished
yes
yes yes i can practice now you can say
this what i can
it's the law of probability i think
we're going to defeat this we're going
to do that i'm going to go that's me
that's right
i know when you say you need to know
listen it's a true true
genuine miraculous prophecy and what is
a probable
yeah definitely definitely and you know
what i want to give you i want to give
you
who is the hymn who takes all the sin in
isaiah 53
chapter 6 and sorry verse 6 and verse 12
that is the messiah psalm 22 he will be
pierced
see there are multiple and there are
multiple prophecies
of that and the resurrection now if
that's true
yes why if i show you a prophecy of
jesus that's not true
and he had to be born in bethlehem okay
i'm a ruler over israel whose days are
from eternity from everlasting
that was written 500 years before that
happened okay dave if you're going to
have a choice of ways but that's
miraculous
i'm not talking about a general if your
condition
if your condition is prophecies you're
definitely accepting islam
hands down if your condition is that i
want to give you this book here
this book is called the forbidden
prophecies it's wrong by uh
this talks about all the prophecies
people made this is a gift from me to
you
all of them he discusses all the false
prophecies if your condition is the
prophecies of prophet muhammad you'll
be about to accept islam my that's
these are prophecies as you asked of
prophet muhammad and it shows prophecies
of ancient babylon that didn't come to
be
so it's comparing the two those who made
prophecies that were false
and those who made prophecies that all
came to be yeah if you're conditioned
i've read the quran and i've read this
now you need to read this with an open
mind with an open mind
because because you know why because the
prophecies are there i will analyze this
because we argue you're gambling your
life on the quran yes
muhammad and
yes yes the true prophet what the true
prophecies
are who the truth is of course and which
god who's gonna judge
and i am i'm i'm gambling my life on the
one true god who sent the messiah
and his name is the lord jesus christ
and if you have believe in him
you're forgiven your sins and and all
this information
you believe i know someone else comes no
but you you get it you get it from the
bible
all this jesus look jesus jesus you get
jesus divinity
on the bible you get his divinity him
dying on the cross with his salvation
from the bible
if the bible is not the word of god you
can say bye-bye to all of that yes
okay so your first name seven hundred
times is called the lord he can be
called whatever he likes
if the bible is not the word of god my
name's dave what does that mean well
whatever but his name is
god nobody lord julius the glory
but david that means the messiah it's
the bible
if the bible is not the word of god but
david
if the bible is not the word of god
dave he can be called one million times
if the bible is not the word of god
the same goes with the quran about the
name of the messiah if the quran is not
the word of god
listen to me if the quran is not the
word of god all my claims fall on the
floor i'm asking a very simple question
if you're weak you'll go to hell but if
i'm wrong and the quran's right yeah i'm
going to
no no no no no no the difference islam
is the only religion that says
if you didn't hear the message of islam
in the correct manner
you will be tested on the day of
judgment allah will never punish anybody
until he sends
messengers so in your religion i'm
doomed in our religion you have a chance
if you haven't heard the message of
islam
truthfully no no so now this will be a
testification on the day of judgment
god will say dave you're speaking to ali
ali aliboy some evidence is why you
rejected it i've spoken to muslims for
30 seconds
i've been a believer since i was 19. and
that's what i believe in jesus lord my
life
so here's the thing if when i've heard
there you go i'm hooked up now so uh if
i have hurt and i have heard the islamic
message
and i've rejected it rejected it
rejected on judgement day if
muhammad was the true prophet who i've
rejected yeah
i should go to hell and if jesus is
truly lord and you've rejected that
then you should go to hell because no
problem clear statement of god you have
rejected no problem but we know
the very bible you have you admitted
with your own admittance
that there are 66 books 72 books 86
books
there is passages added in now you you
are pointing
you're putting your your whole entire
your soul at risk
on a book that has corruption i'm
putting my ass
no no no it's not you said it with your
own mouth there's 72 books 66 no i
didn't i said there's
there's actually 60 anyway how many is
that how many 66. according to the
jewish
the way the way the jews said one or two
one and two chronicles one or two kings
yeah they are one book
but according to what the gentile they
have the 66 let's call it 60
but it's not it's all 70 that's catholic
all the apocalypse there's a problem
no no no they think
okay who's mark matthew did they meet
jesus did they
do that no no there wasn't mark matthew
luke and john who are these people
read the new drum jerome's coming to you
of the bible we don't even know what
john he's talking about
reading he's
no no no he says the john we're talking
about this three john's the john the son
of zebedee john the presbyter
and john the apostle which john wrote it
we don't know your point look with us
that's what i'm asking you you need to
do homework
or maybe his name was jack no it was
john now how do you know
how do you know and why don't you know
john the point the point is this yes
look i i put my trust i put my trust in
a one true god that
all the prophets came with the same
message i put my trust in a book that
hasn't been corrupted or changed
i put my trust in a prophet who his
companions lived with him
and went to war with war with him and
shared their life with him yeah we have
transmission going back
you don't know who mark matthew luke or
john is you're admitting that the bible
you have is it 66 72
86 66 catholics
are there 72 books are they 72 well
they're saying
well dave they're saying you're a weed
they're saying euro weed
but they're saying the same don't get
don't get high
don't get high with your own supply yeah
but yeah you know but the thing is
they're saying the same thing to you
they're saying look you are a heretic
you got 66. we got the 72.
and they also have mary they have mary
as the mother of god
not not not doctrine not doctrine not
doctrine the quran is the same
allah is the same yes yes we can have
discussions about allah
but the point is and you have we have
one quran dave go
read that book you got one question
no no no it's like it's not a muslim
okay they say the same thing about you
dave i'm gonna leave all this with you
i need to read that all this with me
dave read the book read the book if
you're truly looking
who's luke luke was a physician he was a
doctor
and who who said and he was jewish all
the evidence points to him
some people say he's gentle but actually
they they even have a discussion
from the dead read it and if you have
faith in the lord jesus christ you can
be safe
it's a free gift
so there you go so it's still rolling